[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
on a vécu avec la piste six jours
extraordinaires donc du début à la fin
avec les premières médailles les
premiers types 10 médailles dans des
épreuves olympiques
programme des jeux il ya deux épreuves
donc ça c'est important à souligner est
ce que je retiens c'est surtout la
dynamique l'aubade de l'équipe les
médailles les performances appelle les
médailles ça décomplexe et les autres se
donnent énormément d'énergie énormément
d'envié aux athlètes et aux coaches faut
apprécier les médailles folle et
savourer ce sont des très bons moments
pour capitaliser notamment sur cette
réussite
[Musique]
d'autre part notre objectif fort de
l'année bien sûr on est à deux ans des
jeux et notre objectif reste avant tout
[Musique]